NBR Superstar and Avid Biden supporter
Steph Curry wants to stop more
affordable homes from being built in his
ultra wealthy neighborhood Curry and his
wife complaining to the city saying this
we hesitate to add to the not in our
backyard literally rhetoric safety and
privacy for us and our kids continues to
be our top priority and one of the
biggest reasons we chose Atherton as
home however a city council member says
they aren't trying to build low-income
government and run housing but rather
town homes that are slightly more
affordable I again turn to our resident
Californian was that me that is you this
is an area that whole area is expensive
it is expensive and it is again the
message here is if you're rich and
famous you live by the different rules
that exempt you from the beliefs that
you espoused uh no wonder he is a
Democrat everybody's hypocrite like
everybody's hypocrite about things or
things that they that they want to ban
but then they like and they all get
found out but this Dems tend to be worse
Hypocrites because they like like
enforcing things on you except when it
comes to them so they're in they assign
this enforcement piece whether it's on
masks or motorcades or parties you can't
go to a party but I can or property in
that sense they'll say like there should
be public housing near you Jesse but not
near me this is like the Atlanta story
right it's like don't do business here
uh but we'll do business there or the
migrant crisis we should all come in but
not near me so this is a consistent kind
of uh pattern that you'll see over and
over again I think we have a map Jesse
or an overhead view of where this area
would be where they want to provide some
of this housing that areas where they
would build it
um not positive but that's basically the
neighborhood so that big house there is
one of the ones that might be
complaining and one of the problems in
areas like this and they're not the only
ones is that teachers and firefighters
and policemen they have a very hard time
affording housing in those neighborhoods
that they are expected to protect well I
have steps back on this one I Am pro not
in my backyard good for instance I am
pro-nuclear power but I don't want a
nuclear waste site in my backyard
Democrats the same way they're booting
out the illegals from The Vineyard
they're they're banishing windmills up
the vineyard everybody does it doesn't
make them a hypocrite it makes them
human if you're spending what 30 million
dollars on a property and they're going
to put low income housing right next to
your property you have a right to
petition your government as a taxpayer
and that's what the American dream is
all about if you pay taxes you should
say how those taxes are being spent and
if they don't listen to them he can take
his 50 million dollar a year salary not
including endorsements and move
somewhere else and then you're gonna
have no tax revenue so watch it okay
this is keep this tape everybody that
was good I he convinced me consistent
all right it's totally inconsistent
consistently consistent can you follow
that judge yeah yeah I mean I could
follow it in fact I saw I saw a video
that uh Steph and uh I think it's Aisha
Curry did for Joe Biden and uh before
the presidential election and they were
talking about how important social
Equity was and I said hmm I guess they
forgot about it since the election uh
but you know when we say low-income
housing everybody needs to understand
we're talking about homes on an acre and
a half plot we're talking about homes
that are more than a million dollars
each on an acre and a half now I don't
call that low-income housing I don't
know where you're from Jess yeah no no
so I think they are real Hypocrites
we're not talking about an apartment
building with a basketball court next to
it we're talking about million dollar
homes multi-million dollars you want to
revise your stance
we didn't read the story
stuff go ahead I was reading about the
weather in Atlanta which was wrong
Jessica so not right they're
multi-family homes the council member
has said it can't be low income because
it's eight million dollars an acre right
here that's nothing that they can get
around but the totality of the Curry's
statement I think makes this a lot
better because they say first of all
they have unique privacy concerns and
threats right there celebrities do have
a different way of living and then we
pay for it well but they even said if it
is not possible to Halt the construction
can we have permitting to build higher
trees so that people can't be in these
Town Homes taking pictures of the
curries because you know that's what
would happen trees just got 10 feet
taller no but that I I think that that
is in line with their value
that's a nice comment so Everyone likes
the curries yeah and they agree they
have stuck to their well looks and they
want to plant trees and I'm all for
planting trees right yeah they're going
to destroy the suburbs and look what
happened yeah what there you have it
I want to Brian Kilmeade I want you to
do me a favor I want you to click to
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube page
this is the only way that I know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great news bites
any great interviews coming your way on
Fox you can get it all here on YouTube
so subscribe right now